for nearly 2 billion daily users it was
unthinkable three of the world's biggest
online platforms facebook whatsapp and
instagram crashed for the longest time
in living memory
a massive global outage plunged the
platforms into chaos for nearly six
hours
so what happened
facebook has blamed a faulty
configuration change for the outage
which prevented its 3.5 billion users
from accessing its services and apps
this seems to have been caused by a
networking issue which removed the
instructions that normally tells the
internet where to find the company's
servers
something called the border gateway
protocol
the internet is a network of networks
and all of these separate networks many
many thousands of them called autonomous
systems they rely on a postal system
that's called the border gateway
protocol and what actually happened
yesterday is we we seem to know that
there was a configuration error so a
glitch in that border gateway protocol
that happens that happens via human
error or via machine error facebook
pushed an update somewhere in its
infrastructure and it effectively
deleted its location from the map it
didn't delete facebook itself it just
deleted its location facebook and all
these other services were very much
still there it's just that no one could
find them
[Music]
normally it'd be quite simple to fix an
outage like this you go back in and
start advertising where your servers are
so routers can start connecting with you
again
however it's been reported the outage
also took down facebook's internal
internet platform facebook workforce
that meant even its staff struggle to
communicate and then stop them from
being able to fix the outage remotely
facebook basically locked its keys in
its car tweeted jonathan zetrain
director of harvard's birkman klein
center for internet and society
unfounded claims that blackout was
caused by a hacker quickly spread even
without facebook's help a platform let's
not forget notorious for its conspiracy
theories there were some posts on
underground hacking forums claiming to
have data stolen from facebook but most
experts believe these are just
opportunistic scams
however security experts have said that
human error or sabotage by someone on
the inside are both plausible
explanations for the outage
after the services were back in action
facebook chief executive mark zuckerberg
posted on the platform
facebook instagram whatsapp and
messenger are coming back online now
sorry for the disruption today i know
how much you rely on our services to
stay connected with the people you care
about
he said there was no evidence that
facebook's users data had been
compromised because of the crash
[Music]
the fact that it affected the entire
company whatsapp instagram and facebook
for such a long period of time cost the
company 100 over 100 million dollars
across mark zuckerberg himself over six
billion
uh dollars is something they should
really be asking themselves
in response to the blackout the head of
instagram adam merceri tweeted that it
felt like a snow day
twitter and tiktok reported higher than
normal usage with twitter posting hello
literally everyone
it's almost routine for large networks
to suffer outages but what stunned
experts is how facebook failed across
its entire business
these single point failures are hard to
spot especially when they're part of
your core network infrastructure until
they fail the blackout will likely mean
facebook moves away from over-reliance
on one single system
but it's such a big piece of the
internet doing that could take some time
but now at least it's users and let's
face it that's most of us are back
online